Google Cast is a technology that let's
you connect your application to the TV.
The biggest and
most beautiful screen in the home.
In this lesson,
we'll learn how to add Cast Support
to your existing Android app.
We'll cover the basics of
sender receiver topology, and
show them in action by adding Cast
Support to the Universal Media Player.
Here's how UAMP looks when we start.
And here it is after we've added Cast.
Now you'll be able to do this.
That's how easy it is to Cast
your app to the big screen.
Now as Timothy mentioned,
the average TV viewer spends about
three hours a day in front
of their television.
Google Cast is an opportunity for
you to capture that time and
engage with your users in new and
exciting ways.